[Music]  [Music]  yeah we put the the you know happy end  just seeing the scale of it is  incredible it's it's almost surreal to  us and just being in the building that  feeling is pretty incredible people who  do not quite understand the loss and  aggregation they can actually do the  crease and get more information from  their photo wall over there it's very  well done so we go we take a photo  though all Sony member states the flags  and we feel so like what part of the EU  my favorite part of this Center with the  group the interactive room the most  interesting film that I saw today was  they won a Nobel Prize  that's a I don't even know that Wow I  think that it should be visited by  everyone an amazing educational  experience were very grateful for this  opportunity